How are you, everyone?
[ Applause ]
CHRIS: I'm Chris.
I work at Facebook.
I'm an engineering manager on the JavaScript
Tools Team in London and today I'm going to
talk about building high-quality --
[ Lapse in Audio ]
-- and to make -- and I'd like to show you
how we applied a product mindset to Jest,
our JavaScript framework that aims to make
testing painless and I want to show you how
it works to rebuild it.
By a quick show of hands, how many people
have heard of Jest?
Who is using Jest?
Okay.
That's awesome.
If you're using it already, I'm not going
to try to convince you but if you're not using
it, I want to convince you more.
So unfortunately, testing with Jest wasn't
as painless as we wanted it to be.
Everyone was starting to adopt Jest, you know?
And I'm not making this up.
This is an actual tweet about Jest from about
two years ago.
This is never something you want to hear from
a project.
We knew we had some work to do.
And at Facebook, it wasn't that much better.
Jest worked okay as a tool so, you know, write
tests for your JavaScript applications but
here's the thing, in this oil painting, you
can see a party going on here.
And this Jester, he's so gloomy, and sad.
And this is literally the experience that
people had at Facebook when they were dealing
with JavaScript testing.
Everybody was super excited about building
React applications but we found that no one
was actually writing any tests because scripting
with Jest wasn't great.
And so we decided to rebuild Jest and turn
that sad Jester to a happy one.
But you might be asking yourself: Hold on.
Who needs testing?
Who cares?
We realize that Jest isn't great, but maybe
we can get by without any testing.
But, of course, testing is an important part
of the engineering process.
It significantly influences engineering behavior
and we learn that people write differently
with or without a test framework.
And to be specific about this, it helps by
enabling a faster iterative development cycle.
It makes sure you have four bugs in your applications
and you can make releases more often.
So when we go on to improve testing, we can
look at it as we would at any product.
You know, like, what do you do with it and
how can we make that experience better?
So for Jest, it's about what do you want when
you're writing a test runner, and what do
you want when you're writing tests?
For running tests, I should get feedback as
soon as possible, it should give me a signal
for failing immediately.
But for writing tests, I want to have all
of them available to me but also I want great
documentation to I can learn how to write
effective tests and as we developed these
requirements, we can come up with three things.
One of them is performance, the other one
is features, and then adoptability.
All three of these requirements, they're equally
important.
You need to fulfill all of them at the same
time to make a successful product.
For example, if you're building the most feature
rich test runner, but then it's really, really
slow, nobody is going to adopt it, and, at
the same time, if you're building a really,
really fast test runner, with no features,
again, nobody will adopt it.
And, of course, if you are building the most
amazing test runner, and nobody's using it,
then what's the point of all of this?
So I gave you a bunch of buzzwords but if
we peel this product layer back a little bit
and look at an emoji, about what it was like
an engineer working on this, this was really,
really hard and painful.
We had something that didn't work well and
we had to fix it.
And I came up with these three things that
help -- that help you understand this process
to make something great and it's: Fix, rewrite,
and polish.
It's kind of like FRP, functional reactive
programming, but this is fix, rewrite, and
polish.
And let me take you through this journey by
talking about the three major requirements.
And first is performance.
Performance at scale is really important actually.
At Facebook, we realized we had thousand of
test suites and a slow test runner and so
we fixed that.
And, naturally, your instincts would tell
you, let's rebuild the new thing.
But at Facebook we couldn't do that.
But we learned from past experience that big
rewrites take longer than anticipated and
sometimes they don't even work out at all.
So we decided to improve our testing framework
by not explicitly rewriting the whole thing,
but by making major changes incrementally
in small parts of the framework itself.
And I want to stress that it's enough to make
1% improvements over time.
Here's where it helped.
Internally, at Facebook, we have thousands
of test files and tens of thousands of modules.
You know, we have a lot of information that
we need to keep track of to run tests.
It's not just which tests are associated with
which modules, it's also which modules are
associated with which tests so that we can
run the correct tests when files are changing.
So we rebuild the system that analyzes the
entire file system, and then extracts metadata
from all the files that we care about, and
then also tracks dependencies.
For example, if you're using Jest and you're
using the store file up there, it knows not
to use the entire store test, with all the
thousands of files we have.
We also have a system that parallelizes across
worker processes by looking at data from previous
test runs.
That makes tests a lot faster.
And then as a told you, we made a lot of small
improvements over time.
We changed how we cached transform files to
make them more effective.
We improved the -- because we haven't, like,
worked at Jest for a while, and then we just
figured out what alternatives have been created
since then.
So now that we have performance in a good
state and we can run Jest with tens of thousands
of test files, we need to look at features.
Jest comes with dozens of awesome features
out of the box, but today I'll only focus
on three of them.
First one is the improved output, then we'll
talk about this immersive watch mode that
sucks you into Jest, and you just kind of
stay there, and it's an awesome unit-testing
experience, and then we'll also talk briefly
about the snapshot assertion.
So let's focus on the improved output first.
This is Jest used to look like.
Log messages all over, and stack traces that
didn't matter, and you have a stack assertion
where you're comparing two objects and you
have no idea what's going on, right?
We realized that Jest was okay when tests
were passing but the value of a test framework
is to actually give you a signal about failing
tests and helping you resolve those issues
and so we just rewrote the assertion library
with the product mindset to see, what do engineers
want to see when a test is failing.
So, for example, we color-coded everything
so that you know what is green and what is
red and we're also showing you a div when
two objects don't match up so you know exactly
what's going on.
The exciting thing about this is we gave Jest
its own identity.
When you see a screenshot of this framework,
you instantly know that it's Jest.
It's awesome.
We also have this concurrent runner which
is awesome.
It tells you which test is running right now,
and how long it's going to take based on previous
test runs.
What's also awesome is Jest takes a note when
it's failing, and next time you run it, it
actually runs the failed test first to give
you a signal immediately because that's probably
what you care most at that point in time.
The next thing I want to talk about is the
immersive watch mode.
It just runs tests quickly and then shows
you what's happening and then what you want
to do with it.
So when you call it, you call it with --watch,
and then you have the p, for example, where
you have this pattern mode, and then you have
this typing mode where you can select from
a dropdown, Jest knows everything about your
system, and your and knows exactly which version
you have.
In the next version of Jest, we extended this
a little further.
You even have keyboard navigation in this.
I know I've been talking about CLI tools,
but these are all great CLI tools and a great
developer experience in them.
And then finally I want to talk about snapshots.
Have you ever written an assertion like this,
and then you don't know exactly what you're
going to put in your test, you don't know
exactly what the output of your function is?
It happens quite often, right?
We do what we always do, we comment out this
assertion, and we log the value and we take
that and put it back in our test and we know
what is going on here.
And judging from the faces that I see, I know
that you are as guilty as I am.
So we found that people weren't writing inform
tests from code that could benefit from this.
And so we introduced this new assertion that's
called toMatchSnapshot() and here's how it
works.
The first time you used it, it will inspect
the output of your code, and Jest will record
it a snapshot, in a snapshot file.
And then the next time you run it, it compares
the output of your code.
For example, here we're changing a React component
from Facebook.com to instagram.com, and Jest
will yell at you and say, change in your code
has changed, is this intentional or not?
And you can say, I'll pass in a flag to update
all the snapshots.
All right.
And a bunch of you might be looking at me
like, hold on, Christoph, what are you doing
here?
This is not testing here at all.
But we found that it's actually better to
be able to create these kinds of tests for
regression testing, for example, really quickly
instead of just waiting until that code hits
production and that is the first time that
anybody is ever running that code, right?
So it's preventing a lot of issues for people.
And snapshots, I want to be clear about that:
They don't replace conventional testing, or
all the other assertions.
It's just an addition on top of those.
It's just one assertion among 20, or 30, or
however many ships with Jest.
The difference isn't between snapshot testing
and utter assertions, the difference is between
snapshot testing or no testing at all.
There are products like the JavaScript Farmer,
where I'm not confident it would exist in
its current form if it weren't for snapshot
testing.
It just couldn't have moved as quickly.
And as you know by now because I've told you,
Jest is a great test runner, like this jester
in this photo, it takes care of everything.
Which brings me to a really exciting announcement.
It's actually really big but in the end, it's
kind of impressive.
I'm going to show you one more feature.
Have you ever found yourself, like, juggling
multiple projects in one day and you have,
like, a really hard time.
Imagine you're building a React front end
and a Node.js backend, or you're working at
Facebook and you're having a terrible day.
You're trying to debug a bunch of projects
in a single day, and you have a bunch of test
runs on a bunch of different products and
that's not really fun.
So we taught Jest how to juggle and we call
this the multiprocess runner which leads me
to this incredibly unimpressive demo.
In the next version of Jest, Jest 20, you'll
be able to pass anything that you want.
It will watch all your projects at the same
time in a single instance.
Here, it's going to be running a few tests
in watch mode.
I'm starting it up with a bunch of products
like Yarn, and Jest, and Relay, and React,
and you can run these tests across you will
of these products.
So that's going to be shipping in the next
version of Jest.
And finally about features, I want to say
that the experience should be delightful.
I don't want to fight with my test runner
because only if the experience is enjoyable,
then that will actually make people want to
write more tests.
So now that we've looked at performance and
features, we should also talk a little bit
about adoptability because we spent all of
this time at Facebook to make Jest really,
really good and now it's -- we just want to
you give it a try, right?
How do you get started with this?
The great thing about Jest is we've turned
it into this zero-configuration framework.
It ships with a ton of features out of the
box, and all you have to do is install it
with Yarn.
And then you go on to do a simple test.
And then you just run it.
We also managed to bundle Jest with other
JavaScript tools to form a more cohesive development
experience.
If you're using React Native, or Create React
App, you don't need to set anything up.
This also leads me to another small announcement.
So the JavaScript tools team in London at
Facebook is also working on Yarn, the passenger
manager.
Next week, we're going to ship a really tiny
command that I'm excited about.
It's called YarnCreate and it's extendible
and you can look at it as your new entry point
for any new reaction.
So you can say yarn create react app, or yarn
create native file and you can create your
own like that.
So this is a super sweet way to get started
with something new.
These low-friction ways are something great
and you might even get started on your next
project with Jest, right?
That's not enough.
We also need to figure out how to make Jest
work for you when you're already using -- when
you already have a big project.
When you peel back the outer layer of Jest,
you should ideally also find things that make
sense on its own.
And that wasn't always the case.
Not long ago, Jest was one big repository
without much internal structure.
So we did something super obvious, we introduced
structure by turning it into one big module
in a repository.
We actually split up Jest into 13 individual
packages that can be reused in many different
contexts.
We're talking about pulling things apart from
one big giant thing into many, many small
packages.
This helped with the separation of concerns
between the different modules and it naturally
led us to learning Jest into a platform.
We actually ship all of these packages to
npm and you can install of them individually
and use them in contexts that sometimes don't
even have anything to do with testing.
They range from just like an ESLint plugin,
or a port plugin, or a snapshot implementation,
or all the low-level implementations of Jest.
In Facebook, we use this hastemap package,
in Instagram, for React's native packager,
and and the snapshot package has also been
adopted by another -- and React development
libraries like storybook, and style guides.
And then the Jest Validate Package is a tool
that can help you for your own JavaScript
tools to make them easier to set them up and,
give meaningful error messages to your users
and I'll show you a quick example of this
one because I think it's pretty cool.
I think I'm sure all of you can agree with
me that it's -- if you drop Jest Validate
into your own projects, you can make it easier
for everybody.
So in this case, if you're setting up Jest
for the first time, and you have a typo in
your configuration, it will yell at you and
that's very easy to set up.
So packages help you to consolidate infrastructure
and share best practices.
It's a good case when all the parts together,
Jest, is pretty good.
But the parts, individually, they're also
great.
And by sharing best practices, the way I see
it, the more we can standardized in how we
write tests, the easier it will be for people
to write effective tests.
And then the other effect of the separation
of concerns had was it made Jest more hackable
and we were able to make a great open source
community around it.
For example, which is the editor integration
in VS have interesting code for Jest.
And we managed to merge the generic pieces
back into Jest so that other ADEs could adopt
and provide a great user experience to Jest.
We managed to add two core contributes to
Jest who are not working at Facebook and they're
contributing to Jest on their own time.
So I'll show you an example of that.
So Rahelian Miguel joined, and I was like,
I should just build this type ahead like I
did earlier, right?
And it's a fairly complex feature, and one
day I woke up and Rahelian was like, I found
this really interesting, and I went ahead
and built it.
And I came back and I said, wow, this is amazing,
we have to use that.
And then a couple of days later, he just came
back and said, here's another pull request,
and I rewrote the entire test.
It's awesome.
Let's ship it.
And that was a great experience.
And Rahelian did a ton of great work with
Jest and even presented it at React Conf.
And so the Jest project is easily contributable
to everybody.
We know that there's new contributors to Jest
every week that we haven't even known about
before.
So that's awesome.
And the -- conferences like this one -- there's
tutorials, blog posts, books even written
about Jest, and then, finally, I feel like
we have new conventions about simplifying
testing and writing new tests and I find that
really exciting.
One thing that I'm going to ask you, the JavaScript
community is -- we need help with translations.
Documentation is essential to teach people
how to write tests and if documentation is
not written in the language that you're most
familiar with, it's really hard to get started.
So if you have some time, if you speak another
language, please help us translate the documentation
for Jest.
We would really appreciate it.
But that's still not enough to get people
to adopt Jest.
We need something more if you have an existing
project.
And some people might have seen this slide
before and they're catching on to what I'm
trying to do here.
So I was here about two years ago, and I announced
this concept of code mods to the JavaScript
community, right?
It's, like, this system of how you can transform
entire codebases to new APIs, right?
So there's this project called jest-codemods,
and with jscodeshift, you can convert a project
to Jest.
Here's a small refresher.
Say you have this test with jscodeshift, and
jest-codemods, you can automatically convert
this and print all of your files in a way
as if you have written themselves and export
them immediately in a couple of seconds and
I have a short demo of this.
So I found this project.
All I did so far, I've added Jest, it has
a couple hundred tests and then I just type
jest-codemods.
Not codemod, codemods.
And I've looked at this before, and I hit
inspect.
Codemods break down silos between frameworks.
They allow you to move from one framework
to other frameworks in a couple of seconds.
And all we need to do now is run Jest, and
I've tested it before, so you get a nice performance
speed-up.
That is the wrong version of Jest, also.
I apologize.
We need Yarn for this.
Okay.
This is going to take a couple of seconds.
So this is super exciting.
You can just go to a new test runner.
All right.
There's only about eight tests failing out
of 300.
So I feel pretty good about this.
So I just wanted to send a quick -- it is
not -- there it is.
I'll explain a bit more later.
All right.
We got this, cool.
The best part of this story that Jest code
mods was entirely community driven.
The project was created by the community,
iterated on by the community, and is maintained
by the community.
This is awesome.
As a result, more than 100 companies have
told us they've adopted Jest in the last six
months alone.
Some of them are really big, some of them
are really small.
So it's impossible without code mods.
If we look at metrics at Facebook, the number
of tests people wrote in the last six months
has grown by 35%, which is more than twice
as much as it has grown ever before.
When we improved our testing experience, people
at Facebook naturally started writing more
tests.
And after all this, the experience of writing
tests with Jest is not painful anymore.
And I would even say that it's more than just
painless.
It's now a product that gives confidence to
engineers when they're building software.
And not only did we accomplish that, we also
made testing fun and exciting.
And, finally, I've been mentioning Jest a
few times in the last 20 minutes and I've
pointed out a bunch of major features that
we are going to do ship.
It's been a while since we've had a major
release and we've worked really, really hard
on this.
It's the biggest Jest release that we've ever
made and I was gonna show and ship this to
you right now.
We just need to publish it with Yarn and Lerna
and this is going to be a major -- of course,
it's going to be awesome.
And then I need to merge this.
I'll send another pull request right now,
quick.
Just one moment.
All right.
Sweet.
So that's two pull requests.
I think that's enough for today.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
What you've seen today is that building tools
is successful when you look beyond your own
walls and you collaborate with the wider JavaScript
community.
With Jest, which was a lesson that we learned
the hard way, you know?
But the best part about working together is
that the best ideas often come from people
who you don't work with every day and the
result is products that we can turn with a
delightful experience.
Thank you very much.
>> Thank you, Chris.
How's everyone?
Falling asleep?
Getting more coffee?
Where? save?
Well, okay.
I was thinking of an interpretive dance but
I feel like not everyone wants to see that,
so maybe we're going to skip that part.
All right.
We skipped the awkward part of me trying to
dance, which is great for you and we have
our next speaker, Matthew, who's working at
BBC, and he's going to tell you all the awesome
things that you can do with video and the
browser.
Please give a warm, warm welcome to Matt.